azito mire cet immeuble a été totalement
détruit par les missiles à 150 km à
l'ouest de kiev la ville est pilonnée
depuis plusieurs jours
cette femme en pleurs est à la recherche
du corps de son mari ils étaient dans
l'immeuble au moment du bombardement
il est sûrement sous les ruines nous ne
savons pas ce qui lui est arrivé cet
autre résidente a tenu à entrer à
l'intérieur de l'immeuble détruit elle y
découvre le cadavre de son voisin
je le connais c'était série cause ou qu
on a vécu ici 25 ans nous étions même
ensemble à l'armée à kharkhiv la
deuxième ville du pays a elle aussi et
de nouveaux été bombardée depuis le
début de la guerre ce sont plus de 170
civils qui ont perdu la vie ici
mischa est née quelques jours avant le
début de la guerre à seulement kilos et
demi
il a déjà vécu de telles choses que sa
vie sera forcément heureuse maintenant
il sera le garçon le plus heureux
des villes fracturée et des enfants
apeurés depuis ce 24 février karkhiv a
été l'une des premières villes
bombardées